and we formed a group and we exercise
together i ask how old you are
not really
being paid to exercise on company time
not bad
mariana bayer leads the group
the company suggested back therapy
training anyone who wants to take part
can
we did have men in the group but they
said oh i have a charlie horse
everything hurts i'm not coming anymore
but they have health problems too don't
they
of course but they won't admit it
10 minutes of exercise then back to work
the women assemble oxygen masks for fire
departments one of more than 100
products made by the company
drega specializes in safety and medical
technology
mariana bayer is a seamstress she's been
working shifts at drega for 14 years
unstrength individually i wouldn't call
it strenuous but it's monotonous because
it's always the same movements on the
same machines fast declining machine
between here
nearby a team mostly of men produces
hospital bed supply panels
dryga has 12 500 employees worldwide
their average age is 43.
people's rate of illness increases with
age so drega tries to make its
workplaces more suitable for the
employees
you can adjust the tables as you like
change the height set it to work from a
sitting or a standing position it's your
choice
so when i want to stand i can work on my
feet it's a good thing
do you take part in the back therapy
training
not yet at the moment i don't have any
back problems
but the company has more to do than keep
the employees fit
the head of personnel needs new people
her department is revamping its website
the company's employees are to do some
advertising
working at draeger is fun
we basically develop all the things
firefighters need to successfully
perform their jobs
the company wants old and young
employees to work together
in the past sometimes we were so eager
to recruit young people that we created
retirement models to make space for them
a big mistake from today's perspective
we offered individual retirement
incentives to get people to leave the
company
and today
we wish they'd stayed with us
would like to see mariana bayer stay on
as long as possible she's fit and she's
motivated
can you imagine working until you're 67.
for god's sake now i'm going to work
till the end of 2014.
and then i'm going home
few people can imagine doing assembly
work until they're almost 70.
the company has to come up with concepts
to please its employees
it needs them